dans les coulisses à côté de la scène la
loge de cesaria evora la maîtresse des
lieux nous propose un verbe elle qu'il
ne voit plus pauvres des médecins mais
l'artiste du cap vert continue d'allumer
cigarette sur cigarette
aux côtés de ces arias il y as josé
allari à jour de 1987 entend chanter
dans un bar de l'esmod une accueil il
devient son producteur sont animées
elle passe son temps à dire qu'elle veut
voir plus ss sous le charme de julio
sous le regard photo juillet gannicus
c'est la brière
tant mieux
vicat
elle a suivi des cours de la viande
une enfance pendant des années la police
mme alors à 64 ans a précisé mme bonnet
5 millions d'exemplaires vendus
sin champion des bars du même nom sacré
de la musique en france une autre aux
états unis mais si mme michaud d'or et
de s'assurer qu'il ne quitte pas les
jeunes
voir il est madonna l'avait invité à
chanter à son mariage mais elle a refusé
car aux paillettes ces derniers jours à
pereire comme ici à famille de charmer
les quartiers populaires il engagement
humaine
on fait au mieux
je suis ambassadrice du programme
alimentaire mondial et échoué à ce que
j'aime les enfants j'aime aider les gens
en difficulté
et puis je n'ai pas pour ça que je crie
un problème dit
la peña
ces derniers bords à ses lèvres ces
termes le cas clair à rider pour
récolter les là
oui